Hallo und herzlich willkommen auf meinem Küchenfußboden.
Ich weiß nicht, warum, aber ich sitze hier
einfach wahnsinnig gerne.
Also seid ihr herzlich eingeladen, mit mir
hier auf dem Fußboden zu sitzen und über
grüne Tomaten zu reden.
Ich möchte euch nämlich zeigen, wie ihr
grüne Tomaten, die jetzt noch unreif an euren
Pflanzen hängen, nachreifen könnt, sodas
sie rot werden und ihr bis Weihnachten noch
eigene Tomaten aus dem eigenen Garten essen
könnt.
Ich habe das eben mal gegoogelt, um zu gucken
was da so für Informationen im Internet zu
finden sind, und da gibt's einige Sachen,
die ich absolut nicht unterschreiben kann.
Da steht z.B. man soll jede Tomate einzeln
in Zeitungspapier einwickeln.
Hab ich noch nie gemacht.
Ich weiß nicht, wieso man sich die Arbeit
machen sollte, aber es funktioniert auch ganz
ohne.
Und da steht, die dürfen auf keinen Fall
im Hellen gelagert werden, das stimmt auch
nicht.
Wir lagern unsere Tomaten immer ganz normal,
jetzt nicht direkt am Fenster, aber auch nicht
im Dunkeln.
Es ist eigentlich sehr viel einfacher, als
man so denkt, Tomaten nachreifen zu lassen,
und ich zeig euch heute mal, wie das funktioniert.
Schauen wir mal gerade ins Gewächshaus, weil
ich glaube, da hängt noch die eine oder andere
grüne Tomate an den Sträuchern, die wir
gerade mal ernten können.
Hier hab ich noch ein paar Tomaten gefunden,
die an den Sträuchern hängen.
Sobald es unter 10 Grad ist, für mehrere
Tage, solltest du wirklich deine Tomaten ernten,
weil die an den Sträuchern dann nicht mehr
nachreifen und die Pflanzen bekommen dann
langsam aber sicher Krautfäule, und dann
würden die Tomaten an den Sträuchern einfach
vergammeln.
Das wäre einfach zu schade.
Schauen wir mal, wo wir noch welche haben.
Da oben!
Das ist das Problem, wenn du klein bist und
große Tomaten anbaust.
Hier kann man es sich auch gut gehen lassen.
Wir staffeln unsere grün geernteten Tomaten,
sodass sie zu unterschiedlichen Zeitpunkten
reif werden.
Es ist nämlich so, dass je kälter du deine
Tomaten lagerst, desto langsamer reifen sie
nach, und so kannst du dann noch bis Ende
Dezember immer noch die nachgereiften Tomaten
essen.
Da musst du einfach mal ein paar Orte suchen
in deinem Haus oder in deiner Wohnung suchen,
an denen unterschiedliche Temperaturen herrschen.
Bei 20 Grad reifen die innerhalb von ein paar
Tagen nach.
Dann kannst du sie gleich essen, und je kühler
es ist, also gefrieren sollten sie nicht,
aber je kühler es ist, desto langsamer dauert
es, desto langsamer ist der Reifungsprozess.
Das sind alles Tomaten, die schon vor über
einem Monat geerntet wurden.
Mein Freund hat die in dieses Eierkarussel
reingepackt.
Ich weiß auch nicht warum -Spielkind.
Aber die sind jetzt langsam reif um gegessen
zu werden.
Und je nachdem wie hoch die Temperatur ist,
während du deine grün geernteten Tomaten
lagerst, kannst du das dann auch Takten!
Wir habenen die z.B. extra in die warme Küche
gelegt, damit sie schneller reifen und dann
haben wir eine andere Portion von Tomaten
in den kühlen Flur gelegt, damit sie ein
bisschen langsamer nachreifen und wir ungefähr
noch bis Weihnachten eigene Tomaten essen
können.
Hier ist es zum Beispiel ein bisschen kühler
im Flur und da reifen die Tomaten langsamer
nach.
Hier haben wir auch ein paar hingelegt, sodass
wir in unterschiedlichen Stadien immer wieder
nachgereifte Tomaten essen können.
Und du kannst sie wirklich einfach auslegen.
Du kannst sie einfach da hinlegen und dann
reifen die da nach.
Ich lege manchmal noch ein Geschirrtuch unter,
falls eine dabei ist, die fault, sodass die
Oberfläche auf der die liegen nicht matschig
wird, aber normalerweise passiert das nicht.
Du kannst ja alle angedetschten, verletzten
Tomaten vorher aussortieren und dann ist das
gar kein Problem.
Du musst die nicht in Zeitungspapier einwickeln
und muss dir da auch keine große Arbeit machen,
die Reifen einfach so, ganz normal nach, wenn
du sie irgendwo hinlegst.
Du kannst deine grünen Tomaten ja aber auch
sofort verarbeiten.
Also du kannst zum Beispiel Chutneys draus
machen, das mache ich auch gerne, wenn wir
ganz viele grüne Tomaten haben mache ich
da gerne mal ein Chutney draus wenn ihr noch
andere Ideen oder Rezepte habt, freue ich
mich, wenn Ihr ein Kommentar da lasst.
Ihr könnt mir auch mal schreiben, wie ihr
das macht mit dem Tomaten nachreifen.
Ich mache da einfach kein großes Ding draus
und es hat bisher immer funktioniert.
Wir hatten noch nie Probleme damit unsere
Tomaten auf die Art nachreifen zu lassen.
Wenn ich hier irgendwie Blödsinn erzähle,
dann könnt ihr mich das gerne wissen lassen.
Ich bin immer offen neue Sachen zu lernen,
aber als ich das gelesen hab dachte ich, also
bei uns funktioniert es auch sehr sehr gut
ohne diese ganzen Sachen.
Hier ist es auch gemütlich...bin ich komisch?
Egal!